hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to talk about some squeeze plays
that i have mentioned before so i would
like to make an update on those and i
want to show you an interesting
situation on nioh so let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so in this video i'm
first going to talk about nioh because
we have a fresh breakout here so i think
it's interesting for everyone to see it
so let me quickly
here i'm on a daily time frame guys as
usual i'm building my web by putting
supports and resistances where i see
reactions in the past i also try to
label the moves up in five waves one two
three four five according to earlier to
a theory and i'm using trend lines to
identify breakouts i associate that with
divergences if i see any i check the
moving averages i check the momentum and
i try to build up a view so here on nio
we clearly have one two three with the
third wave extension itself divided in
five waves then a four abc and i think
that we are done with the correction so
it's a bit early guys but i think we
will try to get in in our live trading
portfolio on discord if you don't follow
us go have a look what we are doing
there
here
the real breakout would probably occur
at 47 all right once we trade above that
level
this would be i mean very
likely to go higher but for now we are
only having here a short-term breakout
all right guys if i zoom in you can see
it clearly on a daily time frame we've
been monitoring this level for quite
some time we've been just below all
right for the past four days okay we
were testing this level never closed
above and two days the first time we
close above we also have the natural
support resistance as a support level
that is created by the lows that we had
here so i'm going to put it roughly here
okay i'm trying to see if it matches
okay it doesn't match it's not such a
strong
support
but now it became a support because we
have the breakout so we just take the
recent law and we are probably gonna try
to make a trade around this level all
right so buy here stop loss here and
we're gonna target this level and maybe
even higher
so
i think that you guys like the stock so
once again this is a nerdy situation
we've seen those breakouts faking out
many times in the past so that's why
here to me the only play that is worth
doing is using a stop loss around this
level because if it's not holding we
might very well go lower but once again
i think this is looking very good and in
terms of targets guys i'm gonna use as
usual fib projections
so you guys know where i get this from
on the elliott wave book so i measure
one plus three we have a third wave
extension
so usually in this case we go to the
61.8 so it's only 72.71
but as the recent high was 65 i doubt we
only go to the 61.8 retracement i
rather think we're gonna go to the one
to one or one to one point six one eight
relation so this would bring us towards
the 95 or even the 135 level so those
are my targets for the fifth wave and i
think that of course if everything goes
well if the global market goes higher we
don't have the signal in the s p 500 yet
but it it's looking great so i mean it
would probably take six months one year
but we have a very nice move up to take
between 100 and 300 percent so i think
it's very interesting next one so bbig i
talked about this one already
very tricky guys we tried to get in a
few times we got stopped every time so
we are not in this play anymore but it's
interesting for those who are in display
to see we basically got um kicked out of
the trade here during this fake out you
know we had a stop loss just below you
know it is what it is but still i think
that it's looking good now now that we
are not in the trade anymore as you know
it sometimes happens it's looking great
so we have let's check on the very long
term what do we have
you see we have higher highs and higher
lows for the past year all right so here
clearly there was a reversal that
happened not very clean but you see here
it was noisy then we tested we went
higher so here this was a trend reversal
now the trend is up and as you guys know
the stock is massively shorted let me
have a look at that
okay guys so i am here checking the
shoulder interest synthetic short that i
get from the option market and the
regular short and i check it here guys
so bbig
it was having a crazy amount of
synthetic shot so let's see how it is
right now
up
get synthetic short i compute the data
we lost a lot
i'm surprised it's that small we were
having much more than this
so we lost a lot
okay guys so let's check where we have
gamma so we have right now 14 percent of
synthetic short interest on bbig with a
maximum synthetic shot of 30 so we have
15 of gamma but as you guys can see
before guys here i recalled all the
stocks short interest instead synthetic
and regular and you can see that bbig
guys in september the synthetic shot was
95
the maximum and now then 67 66 and now
it's 30 percent so basically shorts have
covered massively
so we still have some gam some upside
game out so it is still enough to create
some bullish momentum if we move higher
but the truth is that the short interest
is much lower so what can we expect from
here
so as we can see in the past every time
we were breaking this kind of trend
lines
okay
we were having a positive reaction so
here once again we got to fake out so
there is no guarantee maybe the trend
line would eventually be like this
okay so maybe we're gonna do something
like that it's still possible as well
guys okay so just be aware of that so
it's a
early signal as well
let's check if we have some divergences
here
if we had them in the past
yeah you see here we have the bullish
divergence
here
we had the buddhist divergence as well
but not obvious just here then it got
broken but here you can see the four
hours momentum was going higher each
time
and here it is going higher too so we
have the same kind of situation so it
might be the reversal the turning point
and if it is
my target would be guys for this wave
let's measure
the one before as usual apply it here
and we have targets one to one relation
here would make sense as it is total
wave completion so around 15 okay so the
target if we are to move higher is about
15 and the level to break to me to
really be looking good is the
7.75 level so i believe that if we break
that we would probably have a retest
okay something like this and then go
higher so maybe we would try to set up
one more trade here let's see but once
again there are many fake outs in this
stocks i'm talking here about the meme
stocks so
yeah you know we just need to be careful
maybe why then maybe the stop loss would
make sense okay so that's it for bbig
next one guys bmla first time i'm
talking about this one it's an
interesting situation so same thing this
is a shorted stock let's check the
synthetic short interest that we're
having on this one
we have less short total is 11 and we
can see on the option market we can go
from three to eight so we have a little
bit of gamma the gamma is the difference
between the maximum synthetic short and
the synthetic shot let's check if we
have some options on october because the
maturity is tomorrow guys yes we have
some 7.5 it's the biggest figure strike
so just above okay so this might create
some bullish momentum so i think that
here
we're going to use the same technique as
you can see that each time we have this
this market is making higher highs and
higher lows all right so we are trying
to identify whenever there is a breakout
you know sloping breakout
and here we having one clearly so
usually those breakouts that then
retested sometimes with noise like here
guys you can see we have retested it
even quite bad here as well
so we might expect a re-test as well we
didn't see it yet here we had the
re-test
so what we can expect from this stock
i mean right now in the short term it's
kind of neutral all right it can very
well move higher and go to new highs
it's very possible it might also take a
bit more time as we can see each time
there was a breakout it took between
okay one month before really being
bullish so here the breakout occurred on
the 30th of september so maybe one more
week guys okay
so that two scenarios
one is that we move higher right away
but
it would not show anything would happen
be before the 15th of october but this
is where we have the gamma so let's say
that if something happens between the
15th of october it's very likely to be
followed by market makers and other
investors then we can have the other
scenario where we go here find support
which would be a nice level to buy and
play the rebound okay so this is the
second situation that can happen and
where
we have a plan as well so if we start to
go higher right away i would take
profits to be honest around fifty
percent around eight and the other fifty
percent around thirteen okay there are
many bike holders in this kind of stocks
all right so taking profits here makes
sense sure makes sense and actually
leave a bit for the real move up make
sense as well so maybe 30 here 30
percent here and 30 around 25 this would
be my play and i'm rather positive but i
think we might need some more time here
and last one guys utter so i've been
talking about this one for a while so i
want to make an update here
the situation is a bit different
because we really have a sharp move down
to the three area that happened last
year so many bag holders and we can see
them at play here we got this breakout
guys okay so this is the reason for me
to be bullish and since we had this
breakout you can see a b c so twice we
got rejected because of bank holders
around the 20 level i believe we're
gonna go there again for now to me we're
looking not too bad we are finding
support around this level on the yellow
trendline 780 something like this we
have this one in our live trading
portfolio we have a stop loss around
seven
so let's see if we get stopped or not i
hope we will not and i believe that a
strong move up can happen so when
this sharp move down is quite looking
quite bad it needs time for the bulls to
heal the wounds
so i think that it can happen right now
but it can also take a bit more time all
right this would make sense so you know
a strong move up happening maybe next
month something like this i don't know
but i'm bullish here and once again my
exit level would be below seven level
seven i'm out of this trading you know
we we could very well go much lower but
in terms of target here guys same thing
oh let's check the synthetic short
interest on utter so i'm adding bmra
and atar what do we have guys
alright so utter
whoo
huge guys
you see
so in terms of shorts it's the biggest
one so let's check how it was in the
past
so
wow
it's the biggest ever
60 guys of total synthetic shot look the
synthetic shot it was between four and
eight now it's between 15 and 16 so
people add it massively on this one guys
massively let's check where it's coming
from
so
bam
okay guys it's coming from october
so
everything is in october so let's see if
it gets rolled with people loaded
massively on october so maybe if
something happens uh before the 15th of
october it's going to get wild all right
because we have gamma at the 10 12 15
strike everywhere we don't see this
gamma on november yet so if it's not
getting rolled uh we will have less
bullish momentum for next month but for
now we have a lot of bullish momentum
once again we first need to start moving
higher for this momentum to kick in this
is the way it works all right once again
i explain when market makers that are
selling options are short calls whenever
the market goes higher their short
position increases and so those guys
they need to hedge their positions at
the end of the day so they're gonna buy
a lot of shares how many shares that
they're gonna buy they're gonna buy the
difference between the synthetic short
now and what it could be if attorneys
move higher so let's say utter takes i
don't know 50
the synthetic shot goes from 14 percent
to 30 yes so they're gonna buy 15
percent of the share float if utter
takes 50
so
you know they're gonna just create this
massive buying orders that usually
happen during a squeeze so utter might
very well go to crazy levels if we start
to move higher so let's find out let's
see what's happening i'm gonna keep
updating you guys on those videos and
once again i did this one for a member
of the discord that asked me many plays
and i hear selecting the ones that to me
still looking good and last thing guys
it is i think one of the last days you
see the painting which is actually a
photograph behind me it's some
photograph that has been done and edited
by a friend of mine that is living in
hong kong she's an artist
she's a very great person guys so please
go check out her website in the
description of this video there's
nothing to sell there you can just shoot
her a message if you're interested but
just go there and visit the website i'm
sure you would find it very interesting
so that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys